Daniel: Hello and welcome, everyone.
This is the third applied active
inference symposium enacting ecosystems
of shared intelligence.
It is August 22, 2023.
We have a lot of really awesome
presentations and sessions coming up in
the first interval and in the second
interval.
So let's just get right into it with our
first talk.
This will be by Andre Bastos.
So, Andre, thank you for joining and
looking forward to your talk.
Andre: Thank you very well, Daniel.
And thank you for the other organizers of
the Active Inference Conference and
Symposium here.
I'm glad to be talking to you guys today
about my work.
The title of the presentation is
multilaminar Multi Area Recordings and
the Non Human primate that's these guys
right here, macaque monkeys, suggest that
predictive coding is implemented via
predictive routing.
And so what do we mean by these things?
Well, just as a point of introduction, I'
'd like to start by just saying that I
started out working with Karl Friston in
about 2010, and we were really interested
in trying to map the neurobiology of the
predictive coding circuits that have been
theorized and hypothesized onto cortical
laminar architecture, which you can see
here.
And in that work with him, we proposed
that different layers and different
oscillations were involved in either
capturing and calculating prediction
error or predictions.
And so what we do in my lab and I
recently started as an assistant
professor in the Department of Psychology
at Vanderbilt.
And so what we do is we train rhesus
macaque monkeys on tasks which are more
or less predictable and that have
different sensory elements that are more
or less predictable, and we'll get into
what that looks like.
And then we use multilaminar probes, so
high density probes with dozens or
hundreds of contacts that can record
across different layers.
And so this is a beautiful drawing here
of what the layers look like of Cortex by
Santiago Ramoni Cajal over 100 years ago.
.
And you can see this really beautiful
layered architecture.
Layer 1234 is this dense one.
In the middle five, you get these large
pyramidal neurons, and then six on the
bottom.
And so we're interested in my lab
primarily at two levels of explanation.
The first is, what do these neurons spike
to?
What makes them fire action potentials
and excites them?
And do they get more or less excitable
depending on how predictable stimuli
are?
And second, how do they oscillate?
In which frequency bands does rhythmic
activity tend to cause them to fire more
or less action potentials?
And so we record across layers in one
area over here, but we might put in our
electrodes in several other areas so that
we can also capture aspects of cortical
communication.
And these oscillations in this
communication, we think, is really
intimately linked to the interaction
between inhibitory cells, these cells in
red here, and excitatory neurons, these
cells in black that I've drawn.
Okay, so without further ado, let's just
dive right into it here.
So here's the outline of my talk in part
one we're going to be talking about first
an overview of what do we actually mean
by this predictive coding model and how
do we think it may be mapped onto cortex
and paying special attention to the
neurophysiology.
So here's the bird's eye overview of
predictive coding at the level that maybe
a neurobiologist or a cognitive scientist
or a cognitive neuroscientist might need
to know about in order to be able to
apply it to their own work.
And so, here's what I mean by predictive
coding, that there's a hypothesized
circuit that is especially rich in higher
order areas.
So here's like the front of the brain,
which learns about these statistical
regularities of the world and creates
predictions about what is going to be
seen and felt and touched and so on in
the next moment in time and in this
moment in time, and sends those
predictions to earlier parts of the brain.
.
So, to lower order cortex receive these
predictions and sensory inputs, the
inputs coming from the eyes and ears and
all of our sensorium is then compared to
this top down prediction.
And if there's a mismatch, that's a
prediction error and the prediction error
is sped forward.
It's a mismatch response and it can be
used to drive models, drive these
internal representations in order to be
better over time and to make better
predictions.
And in particular, these prediction
errors are hypothesized to be housed in
superficial layers of cortex.
And so that's a hypothesis that we've
been able to test now with these laminar
electrodes.
So let's see how our experimental design
worked in order for us to be able to look
at the difference between predictable and
unpredictable sensory stimuli.
So we train monkeys on what's called a
delayed match to sample task.
It's a classic task of working memory,
where monkeys are trained to fixate on
the center of the screen.
Then there's a visual stimulus, in this
case a car stimulus that's shown.
There's a brief delay in which that
stimulus has to be held in working memory.
.
Then the animal is tested on which of the
three items was in working memory.
The animal makes a correct response when
they saka, in this case to the upper left,
, to indicate that the car stimulus was
last shown.
So we then manipulated the predictability
of this information that was to enter
working memory in the following way.
For 50 trials in a row, we would either
keep the sample stimulus constant, so car,
, car, and that's being depicted by the a
here, or in another context, there would
be an unpredictable sampling regime where
either the car orange or green could be
sampled at any moment in time.
So the animals went back and forth in
being in a predictable context or an
unpredictable context.
And then we asked the question, what does
brain activity look like when the exact
same stimulus is processed in a
predictable regime versus an
unpredictable regime.
And in order to do this work, we
implanted these monkeys with multilaminar
probes.
So these are probes, again with these at
that time that I did this work, about a
dozen or so or maybe up to 32 contacts.
Nowadays we can go into the several
hundreds of contacts along a single probe.
.
We can use MRI guidance in order to
position those probes perpendicular to
cortex such that they'll span each of the
six cortical layers, layer one through
six.
Here you can see the white matter here
below.
And then we sampled from different parts
of both the visual cortex because,
remember, those are the areas that might
issue prediction errors in the case of an
unpredictable sample as well as higher
order cortex which has been hypothesized
to create these internal models that then
issue predictions.
So here's what we found.
We first just analyzed the multiunit
activity which is a measure of the spike
rate.
So how many action potentials per unit of
time are these neurons firing?
And what's being shown here is the
multiunit activity as a difference
between when that sample was
unpredictable minus predictable.
So positive activity means more activity
during an unpredictable sample I-E-A
violation of a prediction or a putative
prediction error signal.
And all throughout the brain from V four,
the sensory area all the way to these
higher order frontal parietal regions we
saw, without any exception that neurons
were much more excitable when they were
processing an unpredictable stimulus
compared to predictable stimulus.
And also, not surprisingly, this started
already at the feed forward sweep of
activity such that these red bars here
indicate the start of significance.
So sure enough, area V four was the first
to show significance.
So more spiking to the unpredictable,
over predictable.
And this activity fed forward up the
cortical hierarchy.
Next, we looked not only at the firing
rate of these neurons but also the local
field potential which is informative
about the local oscillatory activity that'
's present.
So you can think of these oscillations as
massive waves of activity that are
synchronous across a large population of
neurons but of course, are produced
through the interplay between these
recurrent inhibitory bouts of activity.
And so, here's what we found.
We performed this power spectral analysis
again comparing power in the
unpredictable case versus power in the
predictable case.
And we did a percent change metric.
Very simple percent change metric.
So again, what's shown here on the Y axis
is in positive, more power to
unpredictable samples and in the negative
values, more power to the predictable
samples.
Now, what we saw in the gamma range so
that's everywhere above about 30 or 40 Hz
again in all areas very strongly mirrored
what we saw in the spiking activity.
Namely, that there was more of this high
frequency and also the classic low range
frequency in the gamma range.
So in both the low gamma and high gamma
ranges an enhancement of power during the
unpredictable cues.
That was also the case in the theta band.
.
And this makes somewhat sense from the
point of view of neurophysiology that
this theta frequency and this gamma
frequency, they very often track one
another and do similar things in cortex.
Why exactly that is the case?
We actually don't know what the reason
for that is, but that's an observation
that we've seen in many other tasks.
But what we saw in between the theta and
the gamma bands was this other band at
between ten to about 20 or slightly
higher in frequency, this classic alpha
beta band.
And this alpha beta band, this alpha beta
band acted in the exact opposite way.
Namely, there was more power to
predictable samples than to unpredictable
samples.
With one exception.
Area seven A was an exception.
It did have that canonical pattern in the
alpha band, but in the low beta band, it
was actually similar to gamma.
And we think that this might be a working
memory update mechanism.
But for now, we are really stressing and
emphasizing the fact that across all of
these areas, you had this beta signal
that was stronger to the predictable case,
, to the predictable sample.
Okay, so next we had these laminar
electrodes.
So let's look at the difference between
what these neurons are doing when you
record from the so called superficial
layers of cortex versus the so called
deep layers of cortex.
So the superficial layers are layers two,
three.
The deep layers are these layers five and
six.
These superficial layers, they are the
layers that feed forward.
So remember from that introductory slide
that these are the layers that were
hypothesized based on predictive coding
theory to house the prediction error
neurons, because according to theory,
those prediction error signals are sent
in the feed forward direction.
So we then tested that in a second way,
which was to test whether or not those
enhanced signals during unpredictable
samples are more present in layer two,
three.
And that's exactly what we found in V
four.
So when we again take this spiking signal
and subtract unpredictable, minus
predictable spiking, we see that the
signal is more enhanced in superficial
layers of D four.
There was a trend towards that in PFC as
well, but in D four, it was a significant
observation.
And furthermore, when we now look at the
LFP gamma power, this power in the 40 to
90 Hz band, again, we do the power change.
.
So these positive signals mean there's an
enhancement of gamma power to the
unpredictable signal.
And again, now in both V four and PFC, it'
's the superficial layers that are having
more of this unpredictable signal again,
and that's consistent with the theorized
type of circuitry for these canonical
circuits.
Next, we were interested in whether or
not these power changes were blankets
across the board that just overall
increase mu activity and GAM activity
independent of the exact sample that was
being shown or whether these signals were
actually specific to the actual item that
was being predicted.
Because remember, in our task design,
animals were for a large portion of time
predicting that there should be a car
stimulus or predicting an orange or
predicting the green stimulus.
So in that particular task requirement,
it wouldn't make sense if task
representations for all three stimuli all
went up to an unpredictable stimuli that
would be more consistent with just an
overall arousal signal.
But what we were next interested in is
whether or not neurons that actually were
selective for the car, if it was those
neurons in particular that had the
unpredictable signals.
And what we found is that that was indeed
the case.
So we performed the same analysis as
before, LFP gamma power difference for
unpredictable, minus, predictable, but
now as a function of whether or not those
neurons preferred the stimulus that was
being predicted.
And what we found is that the preference
actually modulated this gamma band
activity very strongly.
And so this unpredictable signal change
was more specific to neurons that
actually preferred that predicted
stimulus, indicating that this prediction
was not acting as a blanket similar to an
arousal mechanism, but was actually
reaching down at the level of the
representations that were specific to the
thing that needed to be predicted.
And that was even more the case in the
beta frequency range actually, where the
neurons that didn't encode the predicted
stimulus, they couldn't care less whether
or not that stimulus was predictable.
It was really only neurons that carried
information about the stimulus that was
being predicted.
Those were the neurons that were not
enhancing but diminishing their beta
during an unpredictable signal or said
another way, enhancing their beta to a
predicted signal change.
So here's what we think is going on.
We call this neurophysiological
implementation that we found of
predictive coding.
We call it predictive routing to make a
semantic point, but also a slightly more
neurophysiological and computational
argument that we don't actually find
strong evidence for this mismatch and
prediction signal at the level of neurons,
, but instead we think that this
prediction circuit exists but uses these
oscillations in order to implement what
is predicted.
So here's how we think this works.
So when a prediction matches a stimulus,
as is being shown here, when you're
predicting A and you get a stimulus A,
then the A column.
In other words, it doesn't have to be a
column, but the area of the brain or the
neurons that encode A are going to become
prepared to receive the stimulus A by
enhancing the power of this alpha beta
signal.
So this top down beta from higher order
areas we think prepares a cortical
circuit to receive a predicted stimulus
and it prepares that stimulus by
enhancing that's.
This up arrow here, the alpha beta,
especially in the deep layers, which can
inhibit both the gamma and the spiking
signal in the superficial layers as a
result.
So this top down signal inhibits the
superficial layers and as a result, there
is decreased gamma and spiking and
decreased feed forward output in the case
of a predictable stimulus.
The case of an unpredictable stimulus,
well, stimulus A, just like before, is
still going to be coming in.
But because it's not predictable, that
column, that set of neurons that normally
represents A, was not previously prepared
by an alpha beta signal.
And so the alpha beta signal is
relatively low in an unpredictable
context, releasing the inhibition that
the deep layers exert on superficial
layers and as a result, causing more
gamma, more spiking and more feed forward
output.
In other words, what we are hypothesizing
here is that predictive coding and this
error computation comes about as a
failure in predictive inhibition.
And as a result of the lack of these
mechanisms being in place during an
unpredictable stimulus, there is an
enhanced gamma output.
And that's what we call a prediction
error, or that's what we interpret as a
prediction error.
So here's the predictive routing model
one more time in a predictable stimulus,
top down inputs prepare the column to
receive a stimulus.
That preparation leads to inhibition,
less feed forward output.
In an unpredictable case, those
mechanisms aren't in place, as a result,
more feed forward gamma output.
So that's part one.
That's our cortical neurophysiological
hypothesis then, that we call predictive
routing of how we believe predictive
coding is implemented in the brain.
And next I want to turn to a little bit
more about how these rhythms are actually
produced in the brain, because one of the
things that we noticed from just placing
our laminar electrodes into cortex is
that independent of where we put our
probe.
So here's an example of prefrontal cortex
activity.
We would see these high frequency gamma
waves and superficial layers and slower
frequency alpha beta waves in these deep
layers.
And you can do this analysis very easily
and quickly to reveal this, what we call
spectrolaminer pattern.
And what this is, is simply dividing each
contact on the probe, dividing the power
that you observe at that contact by the
maximum, by the contact with the maximum
power along the probe.
And what this does is it normalizes power
such that a value of one is the layer
that had the most power at that
particular frequency band.
And so, if you look here on the x axis,
this is frequency.
So these red colors are tracking which
particular layer has more power at that
frequency.
So you see more of this low and high
gamma power in the superficial layers.
So that's above zero on the y axis and
more of this alpha beta activity in the
deeper layers of the cortex.
And so in a large scale survey of cortex,
together with Bob DeSimone's Lab and
Diego.
And so I did this partially while I was
at MIT, when I was a postdoc with Earl
Miller.
And I continued this.
Now at Vanderbilt.
So this was a really cross institutional
study and involved multiple labs.
And the reason that that was important is
that most labs specialize in being a
prefrontal cortex lab, or a V four lab,
or an lip lab, et cetera.
And relatively few investigators had
actually done the necessary work to be
able to record with these laminar probes
in multiple areas simultaneously.
And so, therefore, by coordinating and
pooling data from multiple experiments,
we were able to record from a total of 14
areas in this study that we have now in
review.
And what we found was that independent of
the area, we found a spectral laminar
pattern that was highly conserved across
areas.
And so here it is from zero to 150 Hz for
area V four in the sensory cortex, seven
A in parietal cortex, prefrontal cortex
in the front of the brain.
Everywhere we looked, we found that there
was this enhanced gamma power in these
red lines here in superficial layers, and
enhanced alpha beta power in the deeper
layers.
And what we then turn to next is, first
of all, well, let's really confirm at a
histological anatomical level that it's
really these layers.
Is it layer one, is it layer two, is it
four that expresses gamma?
And the same question for beta.
Let's really confirm that that is in fact
the case, because it seemed like a very
prominent hypothesis and a very prominent
observation.
We wanted to really confirm it.
So that's the first part of this, part
two.
And then we're going to get into which
specific mechanisms might generate these
oscillations and how does that inform
computational modeling?
And so then this was work done in my lab
at Vanderbilt, led by a very talented
undergraduate student, actually, Max
Lichtenfeld.
And so we performed these histological
reconstructions.
Here's the probe, an example probe where
we performed these tiny electrolytic
lesions in particular areas while we were
recording here's the overlay of the
laminar boundaries.
So in red here, this is layer four.
And then, of course, we had the
electrophysiology so we could look at the
gamma power, gamma relative power, the
beta relative power, and the point at
which they cross over, actually, we
determined was pretty consistent in layer
four.
And of course, then we also mapped on the
other features of these things to the
layers.
And so here's what we found is that the
crossover, the point at which the gamma
profile in red and the beta profile in
blue, the point at which they cross over,
at which their powers are equal, that
tended to land in layer four.
The peak gamma power tended to land in
layer two or three, and the peak beta
power tended to land in layer five or six.
.
And so we mapped these distances between
these different electrophysiological
signatures or distinct profiles to the
different layers.
And we did this for several different
probes and for several different animals
until we were able to get a very nice
distribution here, which confirmed that
indeed, the gamma beta crossover is
consistent with being at laminar position
zero.
We called the middle of layer four,
whereas this gamma is at the boundary
between layer two, three and beta at the
boundary between layer five and six.
And so here is our current toy model of
what we think is going on.
So we think that there's different
inhibitory neurons that are interacting
with their excitatory cell partners to
generate fast frequency gamma activity in
the superficial layers and in turn that
there is another type of interneuron that
is generating with slower time constants
this alpha beta rhythmic activity.
So in order to examine this, we again
turn to anatomy, we again turn to this
question, well then, which exact
inhibitory neurons are most prominent
therefore in the layers that express
these different frequencies?
And in order to perform this work, what
we did is we quantified the laminar
expression of three distinct interneuron
subtypes that are known to account for
over 90% of the inhibitory interneurons
in the primate brain.
And those inhibitory neuron subtypes are
parvalbumin positive calretin, calbindin
positive.
And importantly, previous computational
modeling work had really singled out the
parvalbumin cell class as the critical
class for generating these gamma
oscillations because of their fast time
constants and strong synapses onto the
cell bodies of excitatory neurons.
And so again we perform this painstaking
histological analysis where you perform
different stains, mounting cover,
slipping microscopy, semiautomated
thresholding and cell counting in order
to be able to then really have a
quantitative view on which layers have
which cell types that are most associated
with these frequencies.
And so here's what this data then looks
like.
We have the gamma and alpha beta
electrophysiology here, and then at the
same time we have the presence of
different neuron types with the three
inhibitory cell classes here.
And then we can perform an analysis to
determine which of these cell classes is
most strongly associated with the gamma.
And here's what we found that in both the
low gamma and the high gamma across over
14 regions, what we found quite
significantly was that it was really the
parvalbumin cell counts shown here as a
function of laminar depth that were
giving us the best explanation for the
laminar profile of the gamma rhythmic
activity.
Both when you take a very wide band as
well as when you perform a low versus
high gamma split, it comes out in both
ways.
So how can this inform computational
models of oscillations?
Well, here's what we think is going on
then.
We collaborated with several people here
on this work, including Sanchez Toto et
al and computational modelers in Spain.
And what we did was we performed an
analysis where we took different
interneurons with different types of
connectivity.
So these PV, these parvalbumin
interneurons were modeled as having
strong inhibitory connections to the
pyramidal cell class and strong self
inhibition, which has been important for
gamma oscillations previously.
And when you hook them up in these
particular ways, sure enough, and you
measure the spectral output of these
neurons, these p two neurons, superficial
parameter neurons, sure enough, they
express gamma.
And when you put in different types of
interneurons with slower time constants
and different types of connections to
these deep layer neurons, sure enough,
they come out with more alpha beta
oscillations.
So indeed, this anatomical work could
produce even more in the future, even
more accurate models of how these
interneurons work together and with
parameter cells across different layers
in order to express these oscillations.
So this is really a work in progress and
one of the first steps towards this and
our ultimate aim is to really pull
together this rich anatomical and
neurophysiological data together with
computational models to be able to
approximate the laminar structure of
cortex to a better and better degree.
This next part here, I'll talk a little
bit about a causal test now of the
predictive routing model with propofol
anesthesia.
So this will be the last part of the talk
here.
And so we were interested in anesthesia.
I got interested in anesthesia actually
through my work and contact with Jake
Donahue over here, who is a very talented
MD PhD student at MIT at the time and was
being co mentored by Emory Brown and Earl
Miller, who was also my mentor.
And so we became interested in this topic
for the following reason.
Well, first of all, as surprising as this
may seem, if you go into a surgical
clinic and you're administered an
anesthetic such as propofol, well, it
turns out that the anesthesiologist may
not know exactly the cortical mechanisms
and the systems level mechanisms for how
that anesthetic is actually working in
the brain.
And it's actually to this day remains
more often than not the case that there's
actually no intraoperative monitoring of
brain state.
It's far and few between the
anesthesiologists that are actually doing
that.
And so Emory Brown, who's an
anesthesiologist himself, is really
pushing for more and more adoption of
simple tools like EEG and spectral
estimation methods by the clinic.
And so our work was clinically motivated,
but it was also motivated by the ability
to test this predictive routing model
when activity, especially in prefrontal
cortex areas, is relatively silenced.
And so in these experiments, we
administered propofol to again these
rhesus macaques and we recorded brain
activity there's, these local field
potentials and spiking activity in the
awake state as well as in the unconscious
state.
And what we first noticed is that in the
unconscious state, there were these slow
rhythmic bouts of activity at about 1
cycle per second, or slightly little
faster, a little slower than that.
Those are the slow frequencies.
And these slow frequencies organize these
massive bouts of spiking, which could
sometimes be very synchronous across
cortex, but that there were long periods
of silence in between these bouts of
spiking in the unconscious state.
And so propofol anesthesia, we found is
accompanied by, again, these strong
increases in slow frequency activity,
which create alternating on and off
periods for spiking.
There's reduced spiking activity
throughout the network, but the strongest
reductions are in prefrontal cortex.
And sensory areas are relatively spared.
So they're still quite reduced in their
excitability in the unconscious state,
but prefrontal cortex is more inhibited.
There is also, we found reductions in
cross area synchrony and very pronounced
reductions in the alpha beta band.
And so as a result, we thought we could
actually use this model, this propofol
anesthetic model, in order to test
certain aspects of predictive routing.
Because what's going on here?
We have lower order cortex that's
hypothesized to feed forward prediction
errors to higher order cortex.
And in turn, these higher order areas
might feed back their predictions.
But as a result of propofol, these higher
order areas are profoundly impaired and
very reduced in their spiking activity.
And the alpha beta rhythm is also the
synchrony between areas is highly reduced.
.
So what's going to happen in this case?
Well, if you think from the point of view
of simply everything is going down, then
sensory areas in a response to an
unpredictable stimulus should also just
go down.
But if you think from a predictive coding
or a predictive routing point of view,
the function of these higher order areas
is to create feedback predictions that
inhibit activity.
So in the absence of those feedback
inhibitory activities, you might actually
hypothesize that there would be an
enhancement of the feed forward response
when that feed forward response is
characterized by an unpredictable
stimulus or prediction error.
And so we sought to test this out using
the simple sensory prediction paradigm
where we have a tone stimuli.
These tone stimuli could either be
repeated or occasionally there could be
an oddball stimulus.
And what we would expect is that there
would be enhanced feedback predictions
when stimuli were repeatable and
predicted, and that the occasion of an
oddball would signal an enhanced gamma
feed forward signal.
So we performed the auditory stimulation
task, both in the awake state as well as
after there was an administration of
propofol leading to loss of consciousness.
.
And here's what we found in the local
state, just as we found in the visual
cortex for an unpredictable visual
stimulus, as in the visual cortex, so in
the sensory cortex, my PhD student Sophie
Shang, who performed this analysis, found
an enhanced gamma.
So right at the time of the local oddball.
.
So we have time here on the x axis
frequency on the y axis, and spectrogram
hot colors mean more activity to an
unpredictable stimulus.
So there was an enhanced gamma response
to this unpredictable stimulus, decreased
alpha beta to the unpredictable stimulus.
.
Or set another way, when the stimulus was
predicted, there was more alpha beta.
And here's what happened in the
anesthetized state when we performed this
exact same contrast, we lost the.
Predictable alpha beta signal and instead
everything was enhanced.
So there was a decrease in frequency
towards the low gamma range.
So the cortex just essentially went into
a constant ringing in the gamma frequency
range, which to our surprise was much
stronger in power compared to the gamma
that we saw being enhanced during an
unpredictable stimulus in the awake state.
.
And the way we interpret this is that in
the absence of this inhibitory predictive
alpha beta signal, this gamma signal
becomes uncontrolled and enhances itself
in the local anesthetized state.
Here in area TPT is a sensory area,
should have mentioned that.
So now to conclude, we propose predictive
routing.
So predictive routing is a
neurophysiologically inspired
implementation of predictive coding,
which stresses the importance of these
alpha beta signals for implementing
predictions and inhibiting sensory areas
and areas of the brain that are
experiencing a predictable stimulus.
In the absence of that, you get an
enhanced feed forward gamma output.
And this distinction between gamma and
beta across layers we found was
ubiquitous across cortex, really
suggesting that something like this may
in fact be truly a canonical circuit
motif that's repeated across the brain.
And these alphabetarhmic predictive
preparation or inhibition we found, we
observed was lost in the unconscious
state, with unconsciousness being
mediated by propofol.
By the way, it's one of the most often
used anesthetics, and that as a result of
this loss of predictive alpha beta, there
was an enhanced gamma modulation to these
unpredictable inputs.
In other words, the sensory cortex was in
a disinhibited state.
And so with that, I'd like to thank my
many collaborators and the Bostos lab at
Vanderbilt, as well as collaborators on
the anatomy and collaborators at MIT, as
well as my financial support.
And lastly, we just started the lab about
two years ago, we're still in recruiting
stage, so you guys can check out my
website, my ex Twitter feed, and email me
if interested in contributing to this
line of research.
And so with that, I'll turn it over in
case there are any questions.
Thank you for your attention.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you andre, I'll just ask one quick
question from the chat, dave Douglas asks,
, does propofol change the activity of
neuronal microtubules in any interesting
way?
Thanks Andre.
I'll just ask one question from the chat
Dave Douglas asks, does propofol change
the activity of neuronal microtubes in
any interesting way?
Andre: I haven't looked into the
microtube kind of hypothesis, that's one
of the hypotheses advocated for many
years by people like Stuart Hammerhoff,
and there has been some recent work done
by George Masure, I believe, and so you
should go check out some of his papers on
that topic, but I haven't looked into
that.
And I remain somewhat skeptical to the
quantal explanation for consciousness,
but mostly because the mechanism doesn't
appear at first glance to be very
biologically reasonable.
And also that there's essentially not
very much data on it, but that may change
in the coming years.
So something to look out for.
Daniel: Great.
One other question more generally, how do
you see experimental work in the active
inference ecosystem, and how do you see
the synthesis of theoretical and in
principle, work with this kind of real
wet lab and real recordings on the
neurons type analysis that you're doing
here?
Andre: Yeah, so it's a great question.
I think that what we need to be doing as
a community is having more interactions
between theorists and experimentalists.
And so we wouldn't have performed, for
example, this experiment here if we hadn'
't already been inspired by biological
and theoretical models of predictive
coding and of active inference as well.
And so that's really what we need, is to
make not only hypotheses that are turned
into great theoretical and computational
infrastructures and models, but we also
need to be thinking about if we care
about the biology and we care about
trying to figure out the brain, then we
should also be trying to map those things
onto neurobiology and psychology.
Right?
And so that involves them both
considering the neurobiological elements
that may implement and mediate active
inference in the brain, as well as the
psychological and cognitive constructs
that we think are going to be
particularly sensitive to capture certain
elements of the theory.
And so I remain very welcoming to that
type of and in fact, there's going to be
a postdoc joining the lab soon, eli
Sinesh, who has been working very deeply
in the active inference community.
And so we'll have an opportunity there to
both work on theory guided data analysis,
but also perform more theoretically
guided experimental designs that can go
further into the neurobiological
implementation.
And so this was here what I've presented
really simply the first and small,
somewhat step towards linking the
neurobiological implementation level with
the algorithmic and computational level
of predictive coding and active inference.
.
And so the more interactions that we can
have between the communities, the better
that will be.
I think what would be somewhat of a shame
is if the active inference community went
way too far into just pure theory and
delved into increasing areas that were
divorced from the biology.
So that's, of course, one of the great
critiques, right, of the deep learning
and more machine learning, purely machine
learning driven approaches, is that they
took a little bit of biological
inspiration, but then started using
algorithms like Backprop that were very
biologically unrealistic.
And so, of course, active inference is a
response to that in certain ways.
But in order to continue being that, I
think that there needs to be indeed a
tight dialogue between experimentalists
and theorists.
And so if you have any particular ideas,
I'd be happy to hear them.
Please reach out to me by email or
through X, which you can find here on the
slide.
Daniel: That's really cool.
That's awesome.
You're going to be working with Eli.
And one final question.
This is from Alexandra.
Is it possible to detect the contribution
of Glia to the neural firing rate of the
field potentials?
Andre: That is a question that I have not
considered yet.
So we normally do not consider Glia to be
active in the network, but of course,
that is likely to be an
oversimplification.
We know that they can have interactions
with neurons.
We know that they can also have different
levels of excitability, and of course,
that's how they can regulate neurons
metabolically.
But as far as the contributions of Glia
directly to the local field potential, I
am not aware of how to determine whether
or not they make a significant
contribution.
I actually haven't seen any work on that.
.
But thank you for the question.
It's always good to reconsider our core
assumptions, right, about the cell types
that are most important to capture.
So certainly something to think about.
Thank you.
All right.
Daniel: Thank you, Andre.
Super cool work.
And good luck with everything.
Till next bye.